the top u.s general in afghanistan says
the country could see a civil war
after the u.s military mission ends in
the coming weeks general austin miller
is worried that the taliban
is taking over more territory in
washington the house voted yesterday to
make it easier to evacuate
thousands of afghan interpreters who
worked side by side with u.s
troops two of those interpreters told
charlie dagetta
why that promise is life or death
omid moody put his own life on the line
to save the lives of american soldiers
they hugged me and they kissed me and
they told me from now you're not our
interpreters from now you're
my brother now his life is at risk again
and if we left behind we will be
get slaughtered by taliban slaughtered
by taliban yes sir
a u.s army captain cited an incident
where makamuti identified an afghan
soldier
plotting to kill american troops and
that his actions without a doubt
prevented an
attack while evacuation plans to a third
country may still be uncertain
the taliban death threats here are
crystal clear
i receive a lot of phone calls from them
phone calls yes
and they told me and soon we will come
to kabul
and we will find you and we will kill
you with u.s
forces pulling out military interpreters
topped the target list
and he's not alone omidla was barely 19
years
old when he found himself with u.s
marines immersed
in the very worst of the fighting they
dropped me from helicopter
into the desert you came under fire the
moment you touched down
the moment i touched down i remember
one day in one mission we had
24 ambushes even now he seems
shell-shocked from his experiences
i got shot in kabul city while i was on
a mission
i've been to more than
15 suicide attacks
i'm not feeling well right now the
taliban have said
interpreters will not be in danger as
long as they show remorse
for their treason against religion and
country
would anybody anyone believe that you're
almost laughing you
you wouldn't believe them no i will
never believe them
now he's putting his beliefs in the u.s
government getting him out
before the taliban gets him first for
cbs this morning
charlie dagetta kabul